oh joy in your full sail university you
know interview your alma mater you
talked about being a weird kid which I
can identify with and you said that it
shaped you into having this creativity
in this input that you now use on a
daily basis so talk about that and what
you told them to about weird kids
running the world in the Full Sail
interview that I did in 2010 and I
talked about having grown up and been a
little bit weird I was obsessed with old
radio programs older television shows
and just really fascinated with
storytelling in general comic books just
anything you'd end up distancing
yourself a little bit from your peers
and you get labeled a weird kid I don't
mind I was a weird kid I'm a weird adult
I care about what I do to a level where
it is wholly distracting my hobby is the
same thing as my job if I'm not creating
you know if I'm not working on a reality
show somewhere i'm at home trying to
figure out how to do it or I'm lecturing
on reality TV or i'm just-just I'm
completely wrapped around this one thing
that I've that I really have figured out
that I loved it's okay to be weird
because being weird is a manifestation
of your passion for a particular thing
at a level that other people cannot
necessarily engage you at that level
you're excelling at one thing and it's
okay it's okay to be weird I told you
earlier before we started this interview
weird kids run the world people who are
able to think in an unusual way or be
overly analytical about things that
people might think or throw away you
know one of the greatest experiences I
ever had just recently I did a lecture
its story Expo and when I got there the
organizer was like yeah yeah you gotta
meet Syd field and I met Syd field and
talked about the book and said was like
oh ya dun dun goes yeah he's you know I
don't think people ever think about real
that way and just the idea that Syd
field is acknowledging yes it's okay to
be serious about something that people
look at as a throwaway genre it's tough
matters doing it right matters the
people who are really really good at it
you know you talk about JD Roth you talk
JD Roth can he did what was the show was
was called black and white or something
we're above were two families swapped
races through makeup and interacted with
their communities I mean like nobody
would do that sort of stuff it's too
weird but it was a great show it's okay
it's okay to care a lot about what it is
that you do don't ever get into
something because you think it's a lot
of money there are a lot of people to
get into screenwriting and then I hear
them say I always say what do you think
the median price is for a script and
you'll always hear people saying what's
a million dollars it's this it's this
okay it's great you know even if you've
got a million dollars for a script and
it took you five years to break in and
to kick the doors down you've made a
fifth of that you've made two hundred
thousand dollars minus whatever your
expenses were plus you had to live in LA
the most expensive city there is you're
not living a baller lifestyle trying to
break into anything follow your passions
allow that weirdness to inform you in a
way that makes you unique within your
profession it's okay to be weird so if a
weird kid and his parents said you know
what can we go to lunch no we love you
know our child but he's just not he's
not socializing with the rest of the
kids and he really loves these dinosaur
figures and he loves the comic books and
these things and we wanted to be what
would you tell them I tell anybody and
you know indulge your kids passions
because that's where their outlet is if
you're worried about them being able to
integrate and a crew out with other kids
I can guarantee you there is no kid who
is so weird that there is not another
weird kid out there who kind of wishes
they could meet that weird kid you know
you got you got to let people be who
they are you know my own mother I don't
know
how she put me through art she and my
father put me through art school and
then film school which i always joke is
like the worst parenting you could ever
have is it's just like I'm going to
we're going to help you get you know
useless education and then another one
that's almost as useless so that you can
know everything there is about a total
long shot profession and if I tomato
wrong a left turn in Albuquerque I'd
still be working at a pizza place or
something it's just that thing where you
know be believed in your in your kids
believe in believe in your weirdness and
believe that it'll pay off in some way
so when did you realize that being weird
was an asset I only get too hung up on
the word weird and I see it with the
motion so no it's it's it's almost an
asset because it's I think that there
are there are some people I know who
take reality television as seriously as
I do they don't necessarily look at it
as making widgets they're really great
storytellers there are people I know
that are like finalists in the nickel
fellowship that end up with reality
television and they care about the story
and they want it to work and they get
mad when they can't find the piece that
goes in here it'll it'll work out then
again it's just a matter of if you can't
if you don't care about what it is that
you do if you do it cynically you're
never going to create a product that's
as good as if you're passionate about it
and be just because I chose to run down
a trail that's not screenwriting which
is glamorous which is logical to want to
pursue something that's glamorous
doesn't mean them any less of a
storyteller than anybody who's working
in that genre in that in that corner of
the industry I shouldn't say genre
that's not the word well sure and I'm
using the word weird in sort of a
negative way but really what I mean is
someone that's that sort of thinks and I
outside of the box is so cliche some
little bits I mean a little bit
different from the herd you know and
that is hard growing up but i think if
you harness it in the right way i think
when you're an adult it's it's a great
asset i love the fact that their kids
that are
bananas about science now and I think
that goes back to looking at people who
are a little weird Bill Nye weird dude
but you can you can credit him with
there being an entire generation of
future scientists because that stuff hit
people in a spot where it was okay to be
smart and it was okay to chase science
and you know I would like to think that
reality television can be bigger and
better and more important than it is
that people can be informed by it in the
same way that the people who followed
after Don Herbert and and Bill Nye and
all those guys into the science shows
you know and affected the community at
large positively and reality TV the one
thing I will say is you learn more from
reality TV than you learn from a lot of
other things you know you learn how to
fix your house you learn how to
landscape you learn how to fix your car
you learn different ideas of how to
handle things a lot of the DIY channels
and and things like that it's all about
improving your own life whether it's
aesthetically or personally or you're
starting over reality television has the
ability to be really really powerful the
stories that we tell can empower people
it's not all just entertainment it's
okay when it is just entertainment but I
think that we just need to continue to
work harder to make a quality product so
that people can take us seriously and
not be mildly embarrassed to admit that
they watch it
you